now my question was
um like who actually wants to get
married and why
um yeah that was my main question
he wants to get married and Away in what
in what regard now what are you no I was
asking the men do you want to get
married if not says yes then why if it's
no then why I personally still believe
that marriage is quite beautiful
um I know it's a risk because like as
we've called with the statistics most
women end up leaving but I still think
it probably plays back to my mark
bringing I just feel like marriage is
just a natural Next Step
um in in the progression of a
relationship so you do you want to get I
would love to get right yeah so but I
also think to add on to that to that
marriage is more beneficial for society
because even throughout history if you
look at that polygamous Society it's one
of the things that they see that's
prevalent is there's a lot of like great
there's a lot of crime because
in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which they use
the other men to revolt and cause
problems so monogamy is actually
beneficial to say keeps women safe it
makes insighted by and large more better
nuclear family homes lead to less um
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage so yeah there's
all right but you'd actually didn't
really answer the question like why you
want to get mad you why you want to
again it's a beautiful thing okay you
already said that beautiful yes
physical advantage over that being in a
situation where you're not married yes
so why would like what so it's more
beneficial for kids
children now right it will be beneficial
uh it will be yeah yeah so no the point
I was trying to get at is if like if you
have a reason for why you want to get
married they don't and you believe in
marriage and the vows that you've made
whether it's the god or wherever then
why would you then go against those
vowels and cheat and then it's for some
reason it's okay first of all I haven't
cheated no no I'm just because the guys
have left and they were here before
we're gonna ask them no no I hear what
you're saying but
I hate what you're trying to do I hate
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that married although marriage is
what sought after and it's more
beneficial for our Offspring one the
reason I seek marriage is because it's
better for my kids to be raising a
nuclear family but even though it's
still it's still it's marriage is still
not my biological imperative I have to
sacrifice elements of mice biological
being to conform to the female standard
if I had my way I'd have my woman that I
love and it's women that just chop him
down again if I had my way but to
conform to the social standards of
society
I try to be in a monogamous situation I
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened is
just a prediction of the future do you
get what I'm saying yeah and I think
most people put it that way so I'm just
saying this look if you've got a good
man
and he steps out once in like once or
twice in 40 years listen the grass isn't
green until you water it the grass ain't
green on the other side so I think
that's the thing that women have to
recognize does that work both ways of
course not
okay because men can love multiple women
at the same time or women can only love
my own man and if she's if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now see a guy that you
attracted to you and say listen go [__]
me in the corner right now could you do
that so could you could you do that for
me personally I couldn't most women most
women couldn't yeah so most people don't
want to behave like that you see a man
if he sees a girl he's attracted to you
I will bang you in the bush I'll bang in
the street corner I bang you know it
don't matter it is what it is but that's
the that's the fundamental difference so
so why it can't be flipped around is
because it takes more food to allow
someone in whereas for a man it's like
taking a piss so that's why it's
different but why is it acceptable no I
don't think you get one from and say why
is he accepted no because as if if a
woman cheats yeah there's a reason
behind why she's cheating of course so
then why is it that if she cheats you
can't just accept it it's because it
goes beyond sex there's the emotions
involved that for women to let a guy in
there's a process it's it's premeditated
it's never just a slip up for a man it's
literally I wasn't using my head and I
had a nut to bust and that's that's all
it is but for you it goes further than
that okay but what if it was a slip up
if it was a girl
imagine no that's not a slipper a man
bending you over a glass in your back
yeah she's on holidays that's
premeditated you've gone on that holiday
I want wanting to [__] her brother out
there
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking if you really love a
man you're not you're not looking at
anyone else
I'm saying I said if you are in a
situation where you're married and your
woman slipped up and just one time she
slept with someone just on holiday you
know what uh do you know what you take
us
and you're trying to use the exception
to that
in that scenario I'd like to think but
it can never happen I would just fall
and die if I hear that my immune system
will shut down I'll just get covered and
I'll pass away okay
by holistically that's not how women
behave so how am I supposed to assume
that this is just a slip up and not
something more how can I make that Helen
I'm telling you yeah I'm giving you a
situation no and I hear what your
situation is saying but I'm saying as a
man
I can't assume that that is the case I
have to assuming that the answer is no
you wouldn't take it out no of course
100 because you know because you should
know that me slipping up is literally
just slipping up you letting a man in
it's not it's not because you said it
yourself you couldn't just let a man
slip into a Tonton like that I said me
personally and most women
situation but if he was dating me you
can't slip up like that I'm sorry
I'm saying I'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand or I didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slip up
and then would you take her back yeah
can I just say that women can I just say
that women cheat right women she it got
no it's just it got nothing to do with
life I understand that when women oh
then when men cheat it's a one-off when
we mean she the relationship is finished
think that you've I agree and 100. what
I'm trying to say is that how many women
are the ever woman cheats she knows that
the relationship is finished
nine times out of ten if the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
whatever man sheets it's not the end or
to put it as my mum will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
because they can flick it around
everywhere God hid the women's away
because it's hard to find internal so if
you're gonna go and give it away like
that there's a lot to go through for a
man to get to you internally rather just
on the outside because women are The
Gatekeepers of sex or even more but even
more than that you have to think but the
point guys is like it's not about the
man which is coming back and every time
we know that you're probably gonna sleep
around and come back home the point is
what about us like how do we do you
think that not actually you know
as an impact on your marriage do you
think she gonna be fine no knewing that
you actually eat other
[Applause]
you can go after I'm done okay it men
and women aren't the same and so a man
can have sex with a hole in the wall
they don't care a woman a woman if she
sleeps with some a man he has to be
someone we are not sleeping with bums
out there unless he looks like Michael B
Jordan that is it again like I asked
everyone individually would you get
married and why I lost him individually
would you take a woman back if she
slipped up and it was just a one and
done thing and it was Michael B Jordan
and it was like she had a chance to
would you take her back
no no but but if you did it and you
slept with a random whatever she can
take you back
gonna sleep with a random woman I'm
saying you as yourself I'm asking as an
individual not generalizing Okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice as we are saying
men and women are different if you speak
to women I've spoken to a lot of women
yeah and when they say to me oh
um my relationship ended because my man
was cheating yeah the first thing I say
to them is what did he cheat once and
then you left and they said no he was
cheating is never he cheated it's always
he was cheating which meant this dude
has decided he is going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women number one and
then it was oh no no no no my point is
you are not going to go out and find a
woman who says I went I was going out
with this dude he cheated on me once and
I left you don't it doesn't happen if
women if women don't like things
that cheese yeah exactly even so yeah
even though on your point yeah if I was
to take this woman back do you think
she'll ever respect me so you she's
gonna go she's gonna go sit in the next
man's face for banner and what a woman's
a look
if if you because you have to remember a
lot of relationships are predicated on
on respect yeah if you've lost that
respect for me enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's truly done is when the
woman says it's done the man can say
it's not gonna come back or are we clear
babes listen I'm sorry his dick's hard
he wants to do something you see when a
woman says she's done there's no return
end of end of so for a woman to do that
you must it's done
you know what I'm saying and for a man
the most egregious crime you can commit
is is this loyalty there's no there's no
bigger crime
may I come back to your point you said I
never eat about you know how women say
uh he cheated once yeah you're right
because man doesn't cheat one if it's if
it's cheat one he's gonna come back to
again again again so man doesn't cheat
once in a while or once in his life just
if it is going there it's gonna come
back
do you ever ask why he cheated
a lot of times like girls don't give
their guys sex and are confused when
they trust me trust me I've been there
okay okay 25 of marriages
okay
question then do you do you think six
for your husband is an obligation so
when he wants six you're gonna give it
to him
wait say again a sex in marriage or
relationship and obligation
you should enjoy it obligation like so
I'm saying every time he wants to bend
you over are you letting him put it
inside you is what I'm saying oh if
you're married or a relationship no it's
honestly guys about feelings like it's
about the Bible says no and he seeks it
elsewhere is that a problem you're gonna
say yes but see but that's that's messed
up
because they're what I'm saying I'm
saying because you're just thinking
about what you want you think
because
I'm going somewhere so because because a
lot of times they have kids with the
girl and so well you're adding stuff to
the stuff okay
in the context of marriage yes that's
correct you know context of a
relationship act cool just bounce so
when you're married the difference what
are your what are your obligations from
a man for you in a relationship which
century and what do you what do you want
from a man like what is he obligated to
for you in a relationship well I'm
saying loyalty is up there trust
loyalties up there that's that's a must
but then if you guys are saying that no
no for you yes obligation from a man
yeah just for you but yeah just those
two things well that's one of them I
can't think and list them all up but
yeah the main one is loyalty and to
respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's up there that's well what
if he says I'm only doing that for
someone that's my wife I'll respect you
but I'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
I'm gone that's it what if he said I'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
I'm gone as well then you're gone
you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just
we took my marriage all day and I'm
confused like you keep changing it it's
a marriage I'm usually talking in the
context of marriage but I don't know I'm
not married I'm not married
I've never been married I mean I I even
think in a relationship honestly if he's
not sleeping with anyone else yeah you
should give him sex whenever he wants
whatever he wants yeah
because guys guys want to [__] all the
time so if I'm saying like please don't
[__] other girls just [__] me like then
I should I should get back together
okay wait I understand that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
I'm not in it right now or I'm on my or
whatever
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously he's not one day come let me
let's be real about it that's what I'm
saying but you guys are making it sound
I'll give you one day not too I'll give
you one day in that too
if you missed work one day they might
give you a passive two days in a row you
you'd be getting a pink slip
there's the scenario that you gave us
earlier about
um
yeah and work
you're feeling well
they go all cold
they will still go to work
but if that man wants some sex they got
excuses for it they've got a headache
to go to work
if you
we're saying that a man actually is
going to cheat or is cheating because
you didn't give it enough
yes that happens yes
not showing up to work and you're mad
they got a temp while you're gone
at least you're a job's still there for
when you get back
and fire you just to tell us above I
just think that's the duty to have sex
with your man whenever he wants it
however you want yeah
guys guys before we go again and let's
just reiterate some rules I know we've
got some new people on the panel but
guys one at a time I cannot hear you
they can't a you please let's do this
all right
grocery store
the library I don't care doesn't
that noise
what if we're at a concert listen right
I'm taking it wherever wherever he wants
it I'm gonna be cooking I could be
washing that washing machine wait what
if you're on a podcast
if it's only fans I'm getting paid for
it yeah so but I just think you need to
do it all the time I have a question for
you two ladies because when Auntie's
talking about that earlier she was
talking about it we were like yeah if
that's my man that's my husband why
wouldn't I you two right now your facial
expression your body language is
when she's talking about it it's like no
I wouldn't do that if he wants it I
wouldn't do that all the time
if if no but if if he wants sex all the
time unless you're a man or whatever
then fair enough have sex but the point
I'm trying to get at is you could be
giving him you could be throwing it back
do like you could be giving it to him
all day every day he will still go
somewhere else see someone has the
choice to cheat she's dead and I'll
still have sex with her even though my
girl is giving it to me every day okay
life's about trade-offs no no I'm saying
so like can I just I'll explain so life
is about trade-offs so you can either
pick a guy that other women want and no
he might cheat on you or you can pick a
guy a guy that no other women want and
he won't cheat on you but the thing is
girls pick the guys that other women
want to bang he might cheat but how
would how would you know you you you
know and the thing is like girls act
stupid like no that no I'm not I'm not
I'm not talking about you I'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know know this guy might
cheat like but they know they know what
like you you can feel it on a guy if he
gets a lot of girls honestly like if I
can't express my point of view I wasn't
like about uh the fact if I love that
man I will definitely uh sex with him
whenever he wants because I want it I
want it but if you actually
[Laughter]
talking about like I have two that's
another point I don't have to I want it
it's different like in a marriage it's
supposed to be like that I have designed
I want you because I love you because
there's something between us not because
you asked me and that's one of my duty
which is different I don't have duty if
for one day I'm sick and like I just end
up baby let's say man like you know I
agree with you I agree with you you know
the problem is I think a lot of women
are quite idealistic about future so a
lot of women think about as I am now in
a relationship when you've been there
for 30 years your feelings and emotions
they're gonna be less you know what I
mean
yeah
if you and your woman having good sex
and she gets 20 years older 30 years
older she said no I'm too old she's
talking rubbish banger
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible